fluence that you had you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm
going to do you're going to resign I'm
I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on PE Morgan un sensed after
Jeremy Corbin's staggering refusal to
say that Hamas are terrorist or should
lose power can s st's labor face down
the growing Revolt over its General
stance on Israel Lord mandelson joins me
live for his PE Morgan unsensed debut
star powerlifter April Hutchinson faces
a 2-year ban from her sport after
comments she made on this show about
competing against a biological man she
joins me
live Marie Taylor green one of the most
controversial politicians not just in
America but the world she has Donald
Trump's ear but critics say she's a
lunatic conspiracy theorist tonight I'll
test that
[Music]
theory live from the news building in
London this is Pier Morgan uncensored
well good evening from lond welcome to
PE Morgan uncensored the misery and
bloodshed in the Middle East will never
end and unless people on both sides can
accept some absolute truths Israel has a
right to exist and a right to defend
itself after Terror attacks Palestinians
need a state too with every freedom and
every right that Israelis enjoy and none
of that will ever be possible with Hamas
a terrorist group which perpetrated and
then celebrated an historic Massacre of
Jewish people that is why I repeatedly
asked Jeremy Corbin last night if he
believes Hamas is a terror group and if
he believes they should to stay in power
are Hamas a terror group listen can I
are they a terror group P can I speak
answer the question can I speak are they
a terror
group if you let me speak are they a
terror group if you let me speak I'll
say something go on then a ceasefire
means both sides you said that are they
a terror group listen I said that
because teror group part of the process
are they a terror group
will can we why can't you say it
completely baffling or maybe completely
telling because if you can't answer that
very straightforward question what
possible basis is there for listening to
your ideas about what should happen next
it's very revealing that Corbin's
longtime friend Len mclusky himself an
icon of the British left was able to
answer both questions very easy and
looked like he wanted to pretty quickly
I actually agree with Corbin and the
Palestinian supporters about many things
Israel's undoubtedly oppressed the
Palestinian people for decades Israeli
expansion on the West Bank is playing
wrong and and illegal there are grave
concerns about the soaring death toll in
Gaza as Israel now seeks to eradicate
Hamas but there can't be any moral
ambiguity about Hamas itself they are a
terror organization who just committed
one of the worst Terror atrocities in
history genocide is written into their
founding Charter there's been a shock
reaction from across the political
Spectrum James cleverly posted as Home
Secretary I can confirm that Hamas are a
terror group and here's what David Lamy
labor MP who actually nominated Corbin
to be leader said in Parliament
today they committed the most brutal
attack on Jews since the Holocaust now
they're using innocent Palestinians as
human Shields I'd like to register my
shock that not every member of this
house can say this truth Hamas are
terrorists I also asked Jeremy Corbin
about the time he referred to his
friends and
Hamas 10 years ago 10 years ago I was in
a private meeting in the House of
Commons with a number of people who were
representative of different Palestinian
groups it wasn't attempt to understand
their views and to bring people together
for a short time a person who was
related to Hamas left the room and I
said in a Collegiate friendly and
appropriate way as you would at any
meeting where is our friend from Mass
gone if only that was all he'd said but
it quickly turned out thanks to social
media which always keeps for seats it
was just a massive
Whopper tomorrow evening it will be my
pleasure and my honor to host an event
in Parliament where our friends from
hezar will be will be speaking I'd also
invited um friends from harass to come
and speak as well and the idea that an
organization that is dedicated towards
the good of the Palestinian people and
bringing about long-term peace and
social justice and political Justice in
the whole region should be labeled as a
terrorist organization ation by the
British government is really a big big
historical mistake yeah I think the big
historical mistake was that belief and
that may explain of course why Jeremy
Corbin couldn't answer my simple
questions last night if you can't call
Hass a terror group then frankly I think
you're a terrorist sympathizer it's not
difficult all of this matters because
Jeremy Corbin retains a big following
amongst left-wing people in this country
and he takes center stage at the pro
Palestine marches in my view he does
them no favors whatsoever leftwing
politics are long been dogged by claims
of anti-Semitism because it so easily
Strays into a narrative Narrative of
oppressors and the oppressed with all
the nuances trampled out now sakir stama
quite possibly our next prime minister
is facing a Revolt over his own position
on the Israel war he's refused to back
calls for a ceasefire 50 counselors have
quitting protest a shadow front bencher
Imran Hussein resigned his post in
protest to labor relies on Muslim voters
and many of them are Furious is that
could make the difference between a
majority and a hung Parliament or even a
loss at the next election well starm has
worked hard to drag labor out of the
Corbin crisis but the Israel Hamas War
has created a new one for him and it's
not yet clear that he has the answers
well my first guest tonight is labor
Grande Lord mandelson he served his
first Secretary of State in 2009 as the
leading adviser to to Tony Blair of
course during his tenure as prime
minister and he joins me not Lord mson
good evening hello p it's been a while
it has but it's be back with you it is
it is and I I share the The Joy um I was
watching you watching intently the
Corbin sort of fiasco last night what
did you make of that wasn't a fiasco he
was telling the truth which is what that
that he doesn't believe Hamas are
terrorists that he can't find it in
himself to condemn utterly utterly the
cynical sadistic gleeful coldblooded
murder
that Hamas undertook on October the 7th
he sympathizes with their aims and to be
perfectly Frank I think it's because he
doesn't value the continued existence of
the state of Israel and because of that
view of his that he's no longer leader
of the labor party he no longer has the
labor Whip In The House of Commons and
he will not be a labor
candidate let me ask you he remains an
MP was elected at the last election so
is there any other mechanism given his
position clearly looks like he
supporting a terror group is there any
other mechanism for him to be removed
none that I can think of I mean there
are recall POS uh petitions but that is
I think in particularly prescribed
circumstances so no at the next election
he won't be standing as a labor
candidate if he chooses to stand as an
independent then it will be up to the
people of his constituency and his to
Turf him out and I hope they will it was
I mean it sort of shines a light I guess
on the big debate about the marches
particular the one that's just happened
at arms's day and so on where you have a
large body of people genuinely marching
peacefully who genuinely want to cease
fireing Gaza and I completely respect
that opinion but you have sprinkled
among them in quite large numbers people
whose rhetoric or in regalia whatever it
may be is clearly a step further and in
some cases blatantly supporting Hamas or
chanting things like death to the Jews
or Jihad or for the river to the Sea
they're even calling for a free
Palestine and what they mean by a free
Palestine is free of Israelis so what
should Happ what should we do about
these marches I think you have to
because we are strong in this country
and we have a very robust uh democracy
uh And We Live and Let Live and respect
other people when they express their
views allow them to continue unless
unless they cross the line and when they
engage in racial hatred if they break
the law the police should go in and
prosecute them if as they are Hamas are
a prescribed terror group in this
country if you're a politician who
refuses to call them a terror group is
that a
crime I'm not a policeman I'm not a
member of the crown prosecution service
I can't say uh but you know the
government Parliament has agreed to
prescribe Hamas and let me make this
absolutely clear Pierce if I may there's
a very very big distinction and
separation between the marginal people
who share Jeremy Corbin's view which is
basically that everything is the West's
fault everything sort of starts with the
corruption and collapse of the
capitalist system and everything
everyone else does is excusable on that
basis that is a marginal uh view it his
world anti-western world view there's a
completely differ and separate view
which is shared by many of us in the
labor party which is of course appalled
at the humanitarian catastrophe that's
going on in Gaza as you yourself said in
your opening remarks it it the scale of
Civilian death is terrible the lack of
Utility Supply to the people of Gaza is
unacceptable the continued um uh holding
of uh the hostages is complete
unacceptable the violence on the West
Bank is unacceptable now we can all
unite around that view but the idea that
somehow we in you know the British
Parliament can impose a
ceasefire uh on two combatants in this
war is of course completely ridiculous
we could we could in fact we we decided
to abstain when the UN had a vote on
this but we could have voted we could
have voted as part of the UN to say we
support it well the government chose to
abstain yeah okay they no doubt had
their reasons is that moral cardice not
to say either way a personally I would
have voted against a
ceasefire because we know that the only
ceasefire that is possible is one that
is unilaterally called by the Israeli
side Hamas are never going to call a
ceasefire because it is in their
constitution it's their whole purpose of
being existing to destroy the state of
Israel what does Zama do about this
Rising ground swell of opposition from
within his own ranks his own party who
do want to cease fire and don't like the
fact that their leader is being so
Resolute against
it well he doesn't may be a vote
apparently as early as tomorrow no no
there may well there may well be a vote
but the labor party the labor front
bench uh the leader K sta have tabled a
very good uh Amendment uh to the
resolution which is being debated in the
House of Commons tomorrow which sets out
why uh the labor party supports a total
comprehensive PS in the hu hostilities
for humanitarian reasons but that is not
the same as a ceasefire because a
ceasefire by definition is one that has
to be agreed negotiated and agreed by
both sides Hamas will never agree to
that and so if the Israelis were
unilaterally to declare one they
essentially would be handing on a plate
to Hamas the very victory that they want
they would come out shooting their guns
replenishing their stocks continuing to
fire their Rockets into Israel why on
Earth should the Israelis how can the
Israelis accept that of course they
can't you are a good number cruncher you
know about polling interesting and quite
worrying polling about Muslim support
for the labor party has been plummeting
and ex and accelerating down as a result
of of this war War what do you think of
that and what does K I understand the
sentiment Pierce I understand there's
huge emotion firing people up and I
completely understand why now in due
course this civil
war between Israel and Hamas will fight
itself to a conclusion I believe that to
be the case it may not extinguish Hamas
but it will certainly reduce Hamas and
remove their ability uh to kill innocent
civil civilian Israeli uh people and
that's what is Israel has got to do it
has to continue until this is seen
through and the job uh is done and I
think most people in the country will
understand and accept that but I fully
understand why there are such powerful
emotions when people see the pictures on
their television of this humanitarian
catastrophe what is happening to
families to mothers to children and
babies in hospitals which as we know are
used by Hamas uh as civilian Shields
with their command posts in tunnels
underneath the very hospitals which the
Israelis are trying to get at it's
horrible but I'm afraid it is a
consequence of what Hamas did in the
first place on October the 7th is Muslim
distrust in the labor party a
consequence of
what you were part of with the Iraq War
you weren't Tony Blair you were an
adviser I wasn't in the government at
the time you were an advisor but you
were part of the team advis no I voted
for it I voted for it in the house of
Comm and as you know I was violently
opposed to it um and campaigned against
it and as it turned out the war happened
it was a pretty much a disaster uh I
never thought that Tony Blair
deliberately lied but he got it
massively wrong uh and there was a
massive breach of trust then I I felt
with Muslim people and the labor party
do you accept that I do accept uh that a
lot of people
uh lost a lot of faith uh in the labor
government at the time uh you could
argue that a mistake was made but that
it was an honest mistake in a sense that
what that's what you have said in in
different uh words but we've built back
that faith and that trust in the labor
party and I very strongly believe that
we'll do so again uh when the sort of
sheer emotionalism
uh an intensity of this time has passed
you've got a podcast with the times
called how to win an election yeah you
talk to Kia starmer all the time he's in
he's in a great position but is he in a
great position as Tony Blair was in
967 or was in a position that looks
great but may not be like Neil kenck in
'92 no it's not 92 I was uh I stood for
election in '92 having been the labor
campaign director during the
1980s no this is not uh 1992 but nor
would I say it was yet
1997 uh and I think what K starm and the
labor party have got to do over the
coming year is having people tuned out
of the conservative government I mean
they're not listening to the
conservatives anymore but they're not
yet committed fully to the labor party
and I don't believe that will happen
until next year people won't start
focusing on the alternative they won't
start focusing on the election until
we're much nearer it and it's likely to
come of next year one of the problems
that the party may have other than
dwindling Muslim support is
this a woman can't have a penis I don't
think that um discussing this issue in
this way helps anyone in the long run
what transphobic to say only women have
a cervix well it is uh something that uh
shouldn't be said for the vast majority
of women this is all about biology and
of course they don't have a penis we all
know that that
99.9 something per of women um it's all
biological and it's very straight
forward my position is as I've set out
as I say for
99.9% of women it's a matter of biology
I completely support that who are the
0.1% can you fill the blank for me I I
guess what of of apparently women who
have penises do you know who they are
who he's talking about less than 1% of
women who have penises I assume that
he's talking about women who choose to
identify as women but are not
biologically different no they're not uh
so he's wrong well I believe that they
are uh essentially in a transition
between being having a male identity
that they started with and a female Iden
your percentage I put words in your your
percentage would be
100 my view is is is really quite
straightforward if you have a penis
you're a man but you can self identify
as a woman should you choose to do it
doesn't make you a woman in my view no
so you agree with rishy sun not K dama
um I don't know what Rishi sun is he
said exactly what view is but if he said
exactly the same words as I have used
then it would certainly appear to be
that we're in the same place did you
ever think you'd agree with a
conservative prime minister over your
own labor leader in election year Peter
it's not the worst crime in the
world on a positive note to end
congratulations on getting married thank
you very much to your longtime partner
ronal the Marone old Marone Town Hall uh
literally October the 27th guest Tony
Blair Derek Draper our mutual friend
who's obviously been going through utter
hell with his his wife Kate and K starm
joined us later and K St join later
congratulations thank you it's really
really nice enjoy married life Heaven
Knows Why after 27 years I left it so
long uh who proposed to
who should I tell you how it happened
yes he said you got a big birthday
coming up in October and we're going to
give a big party I said no you are not
going to give any big party for my big
birthday said oh well hold on there be
such a kill Joy we'll get married
instead and we'll have an even bigger
party really yes that's a true story
it's a true story it's a nice story good
to see you again Peter nice to see you
appreciate you coming in Lord Madison on
sensor next a female powerlifter who was
suspended for standing up for women's
rights and Sport on this show I'll talk
to April Hutchinson
[Music]
next we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
play I'm 3 days into the job what have I
done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
SCH today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pompous you mean you're not going
to support mayor Jose L not stop panding
to the nimes to the naysayers and The
National Society for the preservation of
the habitat of the Lesser spotted M the
problem lies in the bureaucracy it's
almost like those highly paid
Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my thank you
there a threat that you'd be worried
about so are you saying that you're
being overwhelmed that you're in dat we
are really working hard for you and
we're just asking patients to be patient
with us are we only going to be trusting
sources like meta and Google and
Facebook and X form you known as Twitter
where is our where is our unbiased news
going to come from Welcome to the talk
it's really great to be back my Little
Darlings kids think all they have to do
is stay at home be silly take pictures
of everything just shut down Tik Tok
then yeah problem problem solve there
you go who's fit as a butchest dog him
all right but but he's now middle class
us here Tess I nearly have empathy when
I'm speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to me
off Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass
talking got former PMS all over the
joint saying things the last you we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King C I
think there's only room for one
king just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk when I say I am
God you think I'm joking or not you tell
me I'm not joking I'd rather do it on
camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview why we'll
explain why how do you feel about that
influence that you have you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there buddy about M Nation yeah yes I'm
going to you're going to resign yeah I'm
going I've been answering your question
you answer mine it's actually not my job
to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth welcome back to on sensor Canadian
female power lifter April Hutchinson's
been suspended from the sport for two
years for taking a speaking
was speaking out actually on this show
about trans athletes competing in the
sport powerlifting Union Ed comment she
made against her rival transgender
record-breaking powerlifter an Andre's
right here on uncensored as part of the
reasoning for the suspension here's what
she said apparently was so
awful so he is a 40 40y Old 6' 250 PB
man well that National Record that he
broke athletes have been CH over you the
stating the bleeding obvious you're the
one now who can't
compete yeah exactly uh I guess saying
uh truth and fact calling uh Andress
abiological male is considered hate
speech and goes against their social
media um code um when talking about
sports Pierce you would know this you
have to State what the person is so I I
was actually thinking I was being polite
saying a biological male um and I was in
fact saying the truth so uh bodies play
sports not identities so when we're
talking about sports especially
powerlifting a strength sport you need
to say call a man a man call a woman a
woman right because physiology I'm
afraid is physiology there's nothing get
away from it um it just seems completely
ridiculous to me that for calling this
out this this shocking unfairness
towards women born with female bodies in
women's sport you can now not compete I
mean it's it how do you feel about
this I I'm actually I mean this was a
week ago that I found out um I was
sitting there on the couch I opened the
email from the Ethics Committee I was
blown away twoy year suspension is very
harsh it's a it's a a suspension you
would give someone that got caught for
doping put it that way so I mean
everyone's still shocked about it I'm
I'm very upset I'm very hurt by my
Federation and I do feel that this
suspension was issued let alone focusing
on my terminology to deviate from the
real Topic at hand which is unfairness
in sports yeah I mean you I saw Megan
rapino the football player soccer of
course over in America um who has just
retired and right at the moment of her
retirement she said oh what I'd really
want is to see trans uh women playing in
the uh US Women's National Soccer Team
which is great because it means her
plays won't get taken and my response
would be okay so what happens if lonel
Messi who's playing in the MLS in
America what happens if he decides to
identify as a woman a he can if he wants
to B there'll be no law against him
prohibiting him from playing for the
American women's national team is that
the way we're going to go where Leonel
Messi suddenly says I'm a woman and
breaks even more records but makes it
irrevocably impossible for an actual
woman to compete um that is where this
is going if we're not very careful isn't
it oh it's it's true and you said it up
uh it doesn't affect Rino anymore so
have fun virtual singling you know
that's exactly what she's doing um it
like for my sport it affects many
lifters I know four lifters off the top
of my head that will be competing
against an coming up and that have a
problem with it that have actually
written the Federation two people have
dropped out one person wait so they
don't have to compete against an it's
not consensual and I mean it only takes
one person to not consent and the
federations that are allowing this you
know it's it's disgraceful it is
disgusting that they're allowing this to
happen yeah I mean it's basically
licensed cheating is what it is and it's
like saying that certain comp
competitors can dope you know if that
was the case everyone will be up in arms
and saying well it's unfair because you
get an advantage this is unfair you get
an advantage I mean there's another
story over here which I know you're
aware of um which has really just
staggered me a health charity in the UK
that helps women specifically suffering
from
endometriosis which is a a condition
about the lining of a womb has now
appointed as his chief executive a
transwoman so a biological male what do
you think of
that I I heard that and I mean what a
huge insult to women you know I went for
a test the other day I went for my first
mamogram and you know I was just sitting
there thinking like how would I feel if
there was a a man in there with me um
you know it's it's a very private issue
um even just going into locker rooms
women are very private like I'm always
covering myself up and that's in front
of women so you take something like so
private like a health condition and you
appoint a man in in charge a huge slap
to women's faces yeah it's not isn't it
um April are you going to appeal against
your
suspension yes so the first first step I
have a great lawyer um uh Lisa buildy is
my lawyer we will be appealing it we do
have 10 days and then after that we will
be pursuing other legal Avenues which I
can't announce right now but uh we will
be uh seeking legal action well I'm very
sorry again that it's come to this and
that this show has played a part of this
ridiculous suspension I wish you luot
with the appeal we'll follow it we'll
keep in touch and I wish you all the
best thank you so much for having me
again good to see well on says the next
my Pack's reaction uh to that interview
and that extraordinary suspension and to
Home Secretary or the ex-home secretary
sella braan and her scathing resignation
letter bitter braan what do you make of
it we'll find out after the
[Music]
break we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thank thanks for
joining us you're watching the
independent republic of Mike gra right
here on talk TV welcome to Friday night
with Nadine here on prime time we like
to speak to the business people behind
big moments good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City very
impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
[Music]
are you actually speech rating for R she
I'm so rich frankly I'm going to take
the side of boozed up Brits against
these pompous you mean you're not going
to support mayor Jose L
not stop pying to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid consults don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather School is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us are we only going to be trusting
sources like meta and Google and
Facebook and X formly known as Twitter
where is our where is our unbiased news
going to come from Welcome to the talk
it's really great to be back my Little
Darlings kids think all they have to do
is stay at home be silly take pictures
of everything just shut down Tik Tok
then yeah problem problem solved there
you go who's fit a bunch your him all
right but but he's now middle class us
here Tess I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to me
up this is talk
TV
welcome back I'm joined by my Stella
pack political journalist AA stina talk
TV contributor paulone Adrian and talk
Tov presenter Alex philis welcome to all
of you thank you uh rather sexist to
have three women in tonight but there we
are thank God there's one man here to
keep the control of them all um right
Miss Santina what do you make of well
first of all what do you make of the
Jeremy Corin interview and mandelson
ripping into him but let's just take
another little look at what Corbin said
last night
are herass a terror group listen can I
are they a terror group P can I speak
answer the question can I speak are they
a terror
group if you let me speak are they a
terror group if you'll let me speak I'll
say something go on then a ceased fire
means both sides you said that are they
a terror group listen I said that
because terp part of the process are
they a terror group
will can we why can't you say
it why couldn't he say it AA it's not a
Shining Moment for him is it I've got no
quarms at all with calling him a
terrorist group I think the argument
from the Corbin Camp will be that
calling them a terrorist group invites
Western opinion to then to to then ask
well why on Earth would you do
negotiations with a terrorist
organization and yeah but obviously the
conversation now is about opening a
dialogue and finding a way to a peace
process and then he also doesn't like
the idea that you can't have a dialogue
with herass can he well I mean even the
conservative there are many conservative
mpes who are now calling for dialogue
with with but because how on Earth then
you get Hamas to release hostages if you
what you don't negotiate with Hamas but
what do you mean that means hostages
just stay there a terror group who have
a who have a stated mission to eradicate
Israel kill all the Jews they can kill
and they've just perpetrated an atrocity
of such scale and and just medieval
barbarism that they're done as a
political force there is no negotiation
with the mass whatever side of this
you're on surely we all agree that don't
we well no I don't deny anything that
you just said apart from the latter half
the latter portion of that which is you
have to have open dialogue with them
otherwise you're not going to get those
hostages back you've also got you know
nearly 2 million people on that strip
that you know they just built a grave
this evening for 180 bodies how on Earth
do you stop what is going on right now
how on Earth do you get to an inevitable
SE open dialogue with them okay Paul I
would flip it around and say how on
Earth do you get rid of a mass which
most people agree has to happen without
doing what Israel is currently doing I
mean it obviously it's horrendous the
civilian casualties obviously it's
horrendous that Gaza has a particularly
high volume of children it's
heartbreaking it's terrible it's awful
but how else do you get rid of Hamas by
talking peers to Hamas but of H of
course you have to course you don't you
don't want to but you're going to have
to we didn't talk to Isis let me we
didn't talk to Al-Qaeda and we know what
happened in Afghanistan no actually with
Isis with Isis we wiped them out pretty
much and we did it unfortunately the way
the Israelis are doing it I mean that's
work with Afghanistan well we we
attacked Isis all over the place and
there were lots of Civilian casualties
now Isis doesn't really operate right so
again I come what's the difference
between ham and Isis you say that but
you know you understand how Isis has
been able to infiltrate certain African
countries and the difficulties
completely finished course they're not
completely finished the C is pretty much
being destroyed never going to get rid
of hamus by simply utilizing serious
much as are Sugg we seriously have
political dialogue with Hamas about some
kind of settlement how are we going to
get the uh hostages back P Alex am I
going mad with you I'm with you you have
to have a surgical operation you
infiltrate the tunnels you wipe out as
many of the tunnels as possible you try
and find your hostages and when you come
across someone who's Isis you arrest
them you interview them you get
information out of them you do whatever
you can and you have to wipe them out
look there's no point to say should be
done what I'm suggesting is one thing
there one thing about negotiating
Palestinian
authorities most of them as well you
cannot you just can't I mean actually
you can sometimes right and we do and I
think it's naive to suggest that we
don't Isis and now Hamas when they have
a nihilistic view which means
eradicating everyone that they oppose
completely which is what Hamas want to
do to Jewish people and Israel when that
is their mission statement there is no
negotiation to be had and they've now
shown what they will do if give if given
the chance and they said last week
through their spokesman if we can do it
again and again and again that's what
we'll do you cannot negotiate with these
people accepting that premise for one
moment then accepting that you might
storm the tunnels and destroy the
tunnels what about the Israeli hostages
that are there what are you going to
tell to the I should release the
hostages but then you've got to talk to
them peers we're going around in circles
you've got to have an open dialog talk
about a peace settlement there is no
dialogue to be done on the the peace
settlement well I think I think we're at
Cross purposes going a little bit around
I think we at Cross pures that's what
I'm talking I think the conversation
that we're having at the moment is
getting to the point of a ceasefire
right or getting to the point of
returning the hostages and see you know
trying to Halt what is going on people
from a ceasefire are Hamas no no but
you've also got the Israeli hostages who
will benefit from that because they will
be returned and and the Palestinian
people who are currently dying why why
are we putting words into the mouths of
Hamas I don't think Hamas are even
offering to return the hostages IDE that
they want to toen in this
brutality ham as many Palestinians as it
takes they don't care let's let's turn
to something else let's turn to this
issue of this powerlifter right who is
now being suspended for two years for
having the audacity to say it's unfair
that a biological male is smashing them
all in powerlifting in the women's
category I actually don't know the
details of the story because I've got to
be really honest with you I mean on the
face of it look I I think if you are a
trans athlete and you have been allowed
to compete in that in that Arena I don't
see I can see why you why should a
biological woman who cries foul about
this and says as it is it's a biological
male competing as a trans athlete why is
she being suspended but if they've been
allowed by the board to compete why is
she being suspended the actual woman in
the situation well I don't know H I
don't know I thought we were talk about
endometriosis I was let's talk about
that forer endometriosis
why why have a trans CEO why have a
biological male for something for a
charity which literally only only
applies to women with a condition only
women get okay so let me answer that
question because I and I need I'll do
that with some analogy so are you saying
to me that a as a a white man you cannot
sympathize or empathize with me
suffering from racism are you saying to
me that because you're a man you
shouldn't be able to treat me as a
doctor for endometriosis or you
shouldn't be able to campaign on my
behalf or if I had say if you're running
charity you have to so you're going to
campaign for me passionately push push
my C you shouldn't be Alex my question
would be P you're cutting me off are you
saying the I'm asking Alex to answer the
question I just think it's all of
Madness can we just stop playing this
Fantasy game where men can suddenly be
women I mean make it stop
ridiculous to me it's just you know it's
woke it's woke to
hyperactive it's trolling women quite
frankly and I'm say look if you're going
to say I'm now a woman that's almost
like saying well biology doesn't exist
and endometriosis can happen to any
struck by the number of women who've
been sensed about this who are not
normally that incensed about stuff
who've said to me I'm enraged by this I
I look are you I think that it's
confected outrage because if you look at
you know who are the normal you know who
are normally treating women in a
maternity War you've got male nurses
there you've got male gynecologists
we've never had an issue before with you
know a different gender treating
biological women for some reason that
there's been this sort of confected
outrage against the CEO look if she's
going to be out there and she's going to
speak about endometriosis which by the
way has not been talked about for the
best part of what forever I don't care
as long as she actually does something
does some scientific research into it
great
okay well there we have it if even women
we stand up for women's rights why
should I why should I po my knows into
it uh thank you pack good to see you all
on say next one of the most
controversial politicians in America
Marjorie Taylor Green joins me
[Music]
live
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up at 9:00 on the independent
Republican Mike gr we're going live to
Israel we're going to find out if there
is going to be a deal to release as many
as 80 hostages out of Gaza by Hamas
we'll be going to Washington DC and more
trouble for the Tories it's all coming
up after
[Music]
Pierce welcome back to un s so thousands
of people rallied in Washington today
against surging anti-semitic attacks
since the Israel Hamas conflict began
incidents in the US has spiked by nearly
400% people from all over the nation
have traveled to the March for Israel
which also demanded a release of
hostages taken by Hamas we're from
Washington I'm joined Now by
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
whose new book called MTG is out soon
well welcome MTG um you are a very thank
you for having me on no my pleasure
you're a very controversial character
depending who I talk to they say you're
an absolute fire brand the female Donald
Trump others say you're a conspiracy
theory wack job how do you
plead well I'm only controversial
because people like you made it that way
Pierce and that's why I wrote my book
MTG what have I done uh people people in
your industry they created a character
of me that doesn't exist and so I wrote
my book MTG so that I could tell my
country and tell the world exactly who I
am and what my real views are which are
not radical they are not controversial
they're actually very American and they
represent the view of not only my
district but most Americans who are sick
and tired of being sell out by
Washington so you never promote
ridiculous conspiracy
theories well if you mean by Russian
collusion absolutely not those are the
conspiracy theories and the lies of the
Democrats and the media I agree with you
about promoted those I agree with you
about that it was ridiculous I said so
at the time well there was no yeah and
we were born out but for example I want
to play you a clip from a guy called
Bassam YF he was known as the Arab John
St
uh and I interviewed him recently about
the the war and he said this about
you the saddest thing that I saw is the
people that were in so much support of
Israel are anti-semite themselves MTG
MTG MTG uh merer Taylor green you know
she said like oh those are I send my
AIDS and they took pictures of the
protesters basically she's surveilling
protesters
and M Taylor green is very known for a
very famous Post in 2018 where she
blamed the California wildfire fires on
a Jewish space laser
gun now you did didn't you cuz I've read
that post I went and got it and I read
it uh November 17 2018 you posted a long
thing on Facebook that was just complete
gobbledygook I mean you made out that
yeah that's why I wrote this book I talk
about Jewish space
lasers something I never said said no
excuse me I never said that phrase that
was a lie about me if you read my
original Facebook post I never said and
that's why I had to write this book
because people like you and whoever that
guy was sounds like one of the trolls in
my social media attacking me and calling
me names when he's never met me um I'm
not anti-semitic at all I support Israel
and I am outraged at Hamas attacking
innocent Israeli citizens women children
sling babies I'm not calling you
anything I'm just saying that you did
post this crazy post basically alleging
you know I know no you know the media
lied about it and that's why I wrote my
book appears because I'm setting the
record straight and I hope people order
my book at MTG book.com it's a great
reading people need to know exactly who
I am who I am and what I really believe
in it's a very good it's a very good
plug for the book but you did suggest in
this post which I've read very carefully
you did suggest that the California
wildfires at the time had be started by
PG and conjunction with the Ross Charles
using a a a space laser in order to
clear room for a highspeed Rail Project
they your words not
mine well you know people have twisted
my words Non-Stop and I guess that's
what you're going to continue to do but
we're working hard America to straight
out our
problems you are you're doing a great
job of it peers and that's what you and
your colleagues do all the time I just
don't I don't handle it I don't deal
with it and I cast it to the side you
know there's a lot of issues happening
that we could talk about I'm going to
talk about but before before we move on
though you have to just accept what you
wrote yourself don't you you deleted it
you obviously you were embarrassed by it
well that would be like that would be
like me asking you to accept the fact
that you defended prisoners at
Guantanamo Bay but never say anything
about January 6 defendants who are
having their rights abused and are
rotting away in solitary convinent here
in our country and especially in the DC
jail you know if we're going to talk
about each other's words let's hold each
other to account to issues that really
matter not social media posts from the I
don't what you're referring to on
guantan Bay but what I would say about
Guantanamo Bay is it's clearly
ridiculous that America kept this
open-ended camp where people were kept
without trial sometimes for more than 12
years it's completely ridiculous in a
civilized Democratic Society that you
would do that now let's move on from my
words well in a in a civilized Democrat
Society we shouldn't be holding American
citizens that simply walk through the
capital grandmothers and mothers and
Veterans walking through the capital
never doing anything wrong and they're
rotting away in jail and being
persecuted by our department of justice
and our government that has has
completely gone out of control so if
you're going to talk about one we should
talk about the other let's talk about
January 6th by all means I mean I know
what I witnessed with my own eyes and it
was a huge vient were you here it was
sorry were you here no I watched it on
television
oh I was here peers let me tell you I
was here I was actually in the house
chamber because I objected to Joe
Biden's Electoral College votes um I'm
very proud of that I would object again
today if I could you suggest I was there
you did suggest that people use violence
to to thwart democracy didn't
he not well you mean like in 1776 when
we beat your country is that what you're
talking about if want I didn't talk
about violence on you want reference
what I did talk about is objecting using
my constitutional Duty that I have as a
mg to object to fraud let me play let me
play you what you let me play you what
you said let's let's play what you said
your own words this is an important time
in our history we can't allow this just
to just to be gone you know just to let
it go you can't allow it to just
transfer power peacefully like Joe Biden
wants and allow him to become our
president because he did not win this
election it's being stolen and the
evidence is there the so the could be no
peaceful transfer of power so what's the
opposite of Peace that's why we objected
PE that's why we objected
andal preg that I have as a member of
Congress let me make there was a law
firm that tried to take me off the
ballot and they were laughed out of the
courtroom in Georgia and you were giving
their talking points I can't tell you
how much people in Georgia would think
give you my talking point which is that
a huge mob of people many of whom were
violent crashed into the capital to try
and thwart democracy mean because people
like you people like you said two things
you mean like the pro Hamas writers no
no I'm talking about occupied our
capital on October
18th self question wait we're we're in
2023 question Pro Hamas mom you've
written a book you talk about capital to
leave can I ask you a
question can
I let me ask you the question I want to
ask well two questions one presumably
when you say there could be no peaceful
transfer of power you mean there has to
be some violent objection to it which is
exactly what we then saw on January the
6th I didn't say violence I
didn't let you do that no peers I'm not
going to let you you're lying I'm not
letting you put words in my mouth that I
said absolutely not you want to know
where the real election interference
happened it happened with Hillary
Clinton Barack Obama and Russian
collusion talk about I've agreed with
youell for four years I've agreed with
you I've agreed with you about Russian
collusion let's agree about that but
let's not agree about the stolen
election I told Donald Trump to his face
and he didn't like it called me a fool
seven times that the election was not
stolen from him he has singularly failed
to produce any actual hard evidence that
there was any stolen election do you
still believe that election was
stolen Piers you're not even a voter in
our country and I can tell you right now
as a Georgia resident and a member of
Congress in Georgia our secretary of
state illegally changed the laws so did
Wisconsin so did Pennsylvania to allow
our states to be flooded with absentee
ballots we have cases in court today you
should look them up Fulton County case
these are cases that are about to be
heard in the next few months excuse me
that we're about to prove those cases it
was you can you can think that all you
want but you live over in brit I'm an
American I'm a Georgia voter I'm a
member of Congress I've seen the
evidence our election was stolen in 2020
and we are going to reelect president
Trump what you're going to do but just
for the record I do have a home in
America and I spend a lot of time in
America and I have lived to work to
America for 20 years I love America I
love Americans I particularly love your
democratic system and I don't like to
see elected officials in America whether
it's you or Donald Trump pretending you
had an election stolen when there is
actually no evidence it was stolen and
in fact many senior Republicans agree it
wasn't stolen if you want if you aren't
able to if you aren't capable of of
believing the truth that's your problem
prove it in the courts it is being
proven it is Count Cas look up Georgia
the right now election PE don't lie to
viewers there are you a liar oh so
you're telling me
Su being pull from under the table Marie
I don't I'm not calling you watched the
vide stacks of ballots being put
through counted over and over Mar as I
said to Donald Trump I'm not saying
you're lying I'm just saying produce the
evidence because no court in America has
so far established any evidence that
that election was stolen it's for the
birds it's cloud cooko that's because
those cases were dismissed on standing
but we have cases coming up PE pay
attention so that if you to know the
truth pay attention to these cases
happening right now let's talk do you
have anything in 2023 do you have cuz
SED on January 6 stolen election okay
what do you got I got a book how about
my book mg this is going your book MTG
book.com let talk about you plugged it
enough you plugged it enough let me ask
you is Donald Trump going to win the
election absolutely he's blowing it out
of the water the primary is a joke and
he is winning poll after poll on the
general election and if he gets
convicted of one of the Myriad criminal
offenses he's been charged with and he
if I'm not saying when if if he is
convicted and he gets a jail sentence
will he be president from a prison
cell absolutely people are going to vote
for him even if he is in jail I would
vote for him even if he's in jail
because we have communism in our country
peers we have the Biden Administration
that is using the Department of Justice
like the campaign arm of the Biden
campaign it's it's unbelievable and
Americans know this that's why people
that are Independence Democrats many
voters are switching over to supporting
president Trump because they're seeing
it for the first time in their lifetime
okay Marjorie we got to leave it there
it was a lively encounter come back
again uh and thank you for coming on us
appreciate it thanks Pierce that's it
for me whatever you're up to keep it un
sensor good
[Music]
night
[Applause]
[Music]